Let's get to the actual
food Certainly, this is choose risotto.
The decisive factor is Sasha's vivid and sharp aroma,
bringing out a little richness and mellowness, and exploding the deliciousness of the eel.
It's smoked
with walnuts.The crushed topping gives it a crunchy
texture.And most importantly, this eel serves as Kansai-
style kaba.Unlike Kanto, it doesn't need to be steamed.
The crunchy and fragrant kabayaki with a strong emphasis on oil
was combined with garlic, which is a strong ingredient.
It's disgusting to think that Baan has lived in it
.
I put this made by Yoshino-ku
and add a few more
dashi.It mixes gently with the cheese made by Yoshino-ku 2-ku 3-ku
and creates a wonderful aftertaste.
Please apologize for insulting everyone,
and I didn't
mean to cook Japanese food.
Super Aggressive Japanese Food